die kommenden jahrzehnte stellen die
welt vor große herausforderungen und
eine davon könnte die moderne medizin
mehr als 100 jahre zurückwerfen mit
jedem verabreichtes antibiotikum steigt
die chance kaymer heranzuzüchten gegen
die wir machtlos sind krankheitserreger
mit antibiotika resistenzen wenn wir
nichts unternehmen könnten im jahr 2050
deswegen jedes jahr bis zu zehn
millionen menschen an multiresistenten
keimen sterben so rechnet das zumindest
eine studie aus dem jahr 2014 vor damit
es soweit nicht kommt arbeitet ein team
aus wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern an der uni gießen und
der uni marburg an einer ki die
resistenzen nicht nur erkennen sondern
auch vorhersagen soll und genau darum
geht es heute ich bin nach gießen
gefahren um dem team ein paar fragen zu
stellen wie entstehen
antibiotikaresistenzen wie viel zeit
bleibt uns eigentlich noch und kann eine
künstliche intelligenz uns bei diesem
problem wirklich helfen und darum geht
es jetzt
im pokal bei den fall dabei
pessimistische sicht wäre das alles
nicht möglich ist dass die moderne
medizin wie wir sie
in jahrzehnten entwickelt habe nicht nur
einfach möglich sein wird
schon vor uns menschen gab es zwischen
mikroorganismen eine art kleinkrieg um
energie nährstoffe und platz manche
mikroorganismen haben daraufhin
wirkstoff entwickelt um andere abzutöten
antibiotika damit sich der
mikroorganismus damit nicht ins eigene
fleisch schneidet haben sie natürlich
meistens auch einen schutz gegen die
antibiotika entwickelt die die
konkurrenz ausschalten sollen nämlich
eine resistenz und das ist ein
evolutionärer prozess durch bestimmte
mutationen überleben einige bakterien
die antibiotika angriffe bakterien mit
diese mutationen setzten sich dann gegen
andere bakterien durch und geben die
resistenz an ihre nachkommen weiter
evolution eben die bakterien haben aber
zusätzlich noch die möglichkeit
resistenzen von anderen bakterien
aufzunehmen also quasi zu erwerben und
weil wir menschen uns gerne etwas von
der natur abgucken machen wir uns auch
die antibiotika zu nutzen ohne
antibiotika wäre unsere moderne medizin
kaum vorstellbar ein beispiel er holt
euch einen kleinen schnitt an der hand
nichts dramatisches desinfizieren
pflaster drauf kein problem wenn sich
die wunde aber dann dennoch entzünden
sollte geht es eben zum arzt oder ins
krankenhaus und die bekommt antibiotika
verschrieben ohne antibiotika können
infektionen aber ein lebensgefährliches
problem werden die entzündung wird
schlimmer und schlimmer man wird
irgendwann sepp tisch also bekommt eine
blutvergiftung und kant hat an sterben
an einem einfachen blüten schnitt in der
hand seit der entdeckung von antibiotika
haben wir aber all das in den griff
bekommen und lebensbedrohliche
bakterielle infektionen wie
lungenentzündungen sind heilbar geworden
außerdem sind operationen und
transplantationen viel viel sicherer
geworden und dieser ganze fortschritt
zeigt jetzt seine schattenseite wir
benutzen so viel antibiotika dass wir
bei der evolutionären entwicklung von
bakterien in den sechsten gang schalten
im klartext je mehr antibiotika wie
einsetzen desto eher entstehen
resistenzen wir üben einen
selektionsdruck auf die bakterien aus
und züchten so immer mehr resistente
keime heran schon jetzt sind
multiresistente keime überall wir haben
sie in flüssen in unserem essen und
mitten im nirgendwo gefunden wenn wir
weitermachen wie bisher steuern wir auf
eine zukunft zu in der unsere
antibiotika nicht mehr funktionieren das
heißt meine entzündung am finger kann
nicht mehr behandelt werden weil der
keim die antibiotika bereits kennt und
resistent ist und dann haben wir ein
ziemlich großes problem wir haben mal
nachgefragt wie es aussehen würde wenn
wir bis 2050 nichts unternehmen das ist
doktor john mensah lolo er ist experte
wenn es um antibiotikaresistenzen geht
und was er uns erzählt hat war super
spannend aber auch ziemlich
angsteinflößend
die pessimistische sicht wäre dass das
alles nicht mehr möglich ist dass die
moderne medizin wie wir sie jetzt kennen
und wie sie sich in den letzten
jahrzehnten entwickelt hat nicht nur
einfach möglich sein wird oder die
anwendung dieser therapie mit einem
hohen risiko verbunden sind nämlich eine
infektion zu entwickeln mit einem
erreger für den wir dann keine
therapeutische möglichkeiten mehr haben
um eine infektion in griff zu bekommen
das würde alles wie wir den medizin
ablauf jetzt kennen weit zurückwerfen
und zwar in die zeit bevor antibiotika
vorhanden waren nun nur hygienemaßnahmen
im prinzip als schutz für die patienten
zur verfügung standen
antibiotikaresistenzen werfen uns
medizinisch zurück ins 19 jahrhundert
und die uhr tickt harmlos eingriffe
können zu lebensgefährlichen operationen
werden
[Musik]
soviel zum beunruhigenden teil aber das
hier wäre ja nicht doktor watson wenn
wir nicht einen positiven ausblick auf
die zukunft hätten also was machen wir
da gegen
[Musik]
antibiotika resistenzen sind
kompliziert sie haben unterschiedliche
wird mechanismen und sind auf
unterschiedliche arten und weisen
entstanden deswegen arbeitet ein team an
der justus liebig universität in gießen
in kooperation mit einem team aus
marburg daran mit künstlicher
intelligenz
antibiotikaresistenzen besser zu
verstehen und sogar auf basis des
bakterien genoms vorherzusagen das
projekt heißt die
hier arbeiten ganz viele verschiedene
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
zusammen unter anderem auch doktor
gianni merlo den ja schon kennt und wir
dürfen das team in gießen besuchen haben
uns die pm aber genauer angeschaut und
haben dabei auch ein paar fragen von
euch aus der community gestellt die ihr
uns über instagram geschickt habt damit
die paella uns helfen kann
antibiotikaresistenzen besser zu
verstehen braucht es erst mal
offensichtlich
antibiotikaresistente bakterien
im krankenhaus werden routinemäßig
proben entnommen bei patienten bei denen
man vermutet dass sie eine infektion
haben beziehungsweise dass sie mit
resistenten erregern besiedelt sind
sobald man die probe mit dem erreger hat
geht es damit ab ins labor dort müssen
die proben sequenziert werden also die
gene der bakterien müssen ausgelesen
werden das ist allerdings gar nicht so
einfach wie das funktioniert und wie es
dann weitergeht das hat uns oliver
schwengers erklärt der ist
bioinformatiker im team von diplomaten
aber man kann sich wirklich vorstellen
wenn man das bakterium gelogen normales
e.coli genome hat ungefähr 4,6 millionen
bausteine in ihrem erbgut und wenn man
das sich vorstellen wie ein buch dann
kann man die sequenzierung ungefähr so
vergleichen dass man das buch nimmt
einmal komplett zerschneidet jeden satz
in ein zwei drei teile und diese kleinen
frickel diese kleinen freeman und
fragment und müssen dann im computer
wieder zusammen gesetzt werden
vor 20 jahren war das alles handarbeit
so hat er ein ganzes team aus
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern quasi ein komplettes
zerschnitten das buch vor sich liegen
dass sie wieder zusammenkleben mussten
damals hat die sequenzierung von einem
ganzen bakterien genom jahre gedauert
und millionen gekostet heute braucht man
dafür nur eine person wenige stunden
oder maximal ein paar tage zeit und das
ganze kostet zwischen 50 und 100 euro
ein hoch auf den technologischen
fortschritt kurzer fun fact die
sequenziert technologien sind
mittlerweile so krass dass man einfach
dieses kleine ding hier an ein
smartphone anschließen und mal eben
einen genom sequenzieren kann und so
wird das übrigens auch da oben auf der
iss gemacht aber zurück zum thema ist
das genom sequenziert also das
zerschnittene buch quasi wieder
zusammengeklebt dann wird es im nächsten
schritt der kg präsentiert und das
spannende ist es ist gar nicht so
einfach einem neuronalen netzwerk nur
text daten zu füttern deswegen muss man
das ganze in eine sprache übersetzen die
das neuronale netzwerk besser verstehen
kann nämlich bild eine methode zur
übersetzung sind so genannte cross game
repräsentations bei denen aus dem genom
2d bilder generiert werden die das
neuronale netzwerk dann besser
verarbeitet die bilder werden ganz
zusammen mit trainingsdaten also mit
bildern bekannter resistenz typen an die
pader gefüttert
man präsentiert einen bart ihrem genom
das netzwerk generiert erstmal rein
zufällig eine ausgabe und diese ausgabe
wird dann mit den bekannten resistenz
typen verglichen dieser unterschied
dieser fehler den kann man dann wieder
zurück speisen um mithilfe von lern
algorithmen können wir dann eben
sukzessive diese netzwerke immer weiter
verbessern so dass sie dann in einem
nächsten schritt einen geringeren fehler
produziert fürs erste findet die pm also
gar keine resistenzen auf eigene faust
sondern wird erst einmal trainiert mit
bildern von erregern bei denen wir die
resistenz schon kennen nachdem der
algorithmus also ein ergebnis geliefert
hat können wir dem system sagen was das
richtige ergebnis gewesen wäre und so
lernt das system dann wichtige muster
zur bestimmung von resistenzen so lange
bis es sie selbst bestimmen kann
normalerweise würde man wenn eine
patientin oder ein patient resistenzen
gegen antibiotika aufweist einfach
weiter ausprobieren bis ein antibiotikum
anschlägt da stellt man quasi mit einer
art ausschlussverfahren festlegen was
dieses bakterium resistent ist durch die
künstliche intelligenz spart man sich
aber dieses trial and error verfahren
die bei elmar analysiert das bakterium
dass die infektion ausgelöst und kann
dann voraussagen gegen welche
antibiotika resistent ist das spart
nicht nur zeit zeit in der die
infizierten sterben könnten sondern das
spart auch antibiotika und je weniger
wir davon nutzen desto weniger
resistenzen entstehen
okay das ist alles super mega spannend
aber reicht das können wir wenn wir
resistenzen vorhersagen das ende der
modernen medizin verhindern die kurze
antwort ist leider nein das bedeutet
aber nicht dass wir jetzt den kopf in
den sand stecken sollten wie auch bei
der klimakrise müssen verschiedene
ansätze hand in hand gehen da muss man
viel mehr schrauben drehen um das in den
griff zu bekommen dazu gehört aber auch
früher oder später das verständnis dass
antibiotika resistenzen ein problem der
gesamtbevölkerung der gesamt population
ist so ähnlich wie es der klimawandel
letztendlich auch ist
und dementsprechend müssen wir an allen
stellen schauen wo wir antibiotika
verwenden und an all diesen stellen muss
diese verwendung optimiert werden also
es darf dann kein kompromiss mehr geben
und sagen ja aus
wirtschaftlichkeitsgründen machen wir
das aber jetzt so in der breite weil es
uns geht das nicht nein da muss man
letztendlich methoden entwickeln um auch
meinetwegen in der tierhaltung gezielt
infektionen zu finden gezielt diese zu
behandeln und nicht die ganze breite zum
beispiel nicht den ganzen thierstein mit
dem antibiotika zu behandeln
viele tiere bekommen einfach
prophylaktisch also vorsorglich
antibiotika so verbreiten sich
bakterielle infektionen nicht im ganzen
schlachthof und sorgen so für große
ausfälle bei der versorgung
beziehungsweise sind wir mal ehrlich für
große ausfälle beim gewinn aber auch wir
menschen nehmen antibiotika zu
leichtfertig und zu viel gegen viren
würden antibiotika zum beispiel
überhaupt nicht das heißt schon bei
einem kleinen stufen nach antibiotika zu
fragen ist nicht nur sinnlos sondern
bringt uns auch multiresistenten
bakterien einen schritt näher
es braucht bessere diagnosen wenn wir
genau wissen dass es sich um eine
virusinfektion handelt dann können wir
uns die antibiotika sparen das problem
ist nur dass so eine diagnose oft teurer
ist als einfach vorsorglich antibiotika
zu verschreiben
das heißt zusätzlich zu systemen wie die
pr markt die dafür sorgen dass wir die
resistenzen besser verstehen brauchen
wir auch neue bessere wege diagnosen zu
stellen und das coole ist auch hier gibt
es in deutschland schon forscherinnen
und forscher die ki nutzen um
patientinnen und patienten zu
analysieren damit können ärztinnen und
ärzte besser und einfacher diagnosen
stellen und auch da weiter letztens und
habe mir das mal angeschaut das video
dazu könnt ihr euch hier ansehen vielen
lieben dank noch mal an alle vor ort in
gießen die uns bei unserem 3 unterstützt
haben falls ihr jetzt noch fragen habt
dann schreibt uns die gerne unten in die
kommentare und wir hatten dann eure
fragen an die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler vom team weiter und
posten euch dann deren antworten wieder
hier in die kommentare ihr könnt also
gerne so spezifisch sein wie ihr wollt
und an dieser stelle auch vielen lieben
dank an das bundesministerium für
bildung und forschung die so eine
wichtige entwicklung wie die pm auf
fördern und auch uns bei diesem video
hier unterstützt haben und dann euch wie
immer vielen lieben dank fürs zuschauen
und bleibt neugierig patrick